what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world and so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
the seven ways to help you find your
purpose and vision so one of the most
common question that I get asked by
entrepreneurs when they're commenting or
leaving me emails or feedback is how do
I find my purpose how do I find what I'm
supposed to be doing how do I then turn
the business around it I want to do
something that I love I hate my job and
I want to find my purpose how do I do
that and so you're in luck because in
today's video I'm gonna look at the 7
ways for you to do it way number one is
figure out your one word I wrote a book
it's called your one word I highly
recommend you check it out it's about
finding the most important core value to
you I think until you know what it is
that you stay in for until you
understand your most important core
value then you're always gonna be living
somebody else's version of your life
where somebody's gonna want you to do
something and you don't know where to
say no or where to say yes to because
you don't come from a place of self
confidence I think a lot of people are
living their life walking through the
mud they're taking very very slow steps
forward and sometimes they're sinking
down because they don't know what the
direction is that they should be taking
when you understand what your single
most important core value is that helps
clear the path that helps give you the
guise and direction to help you move
forward that helps you say no to the
things that don't serve you and allow
you to have that straight path towards
achieving your big goals that you have
for yourselves figure out what your one
word is I think it's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
in your life
[Music]
we're number two is to explore explore
explore if you don't know what it is
that you want to do you're not gonna
figure it out by sitting on the couch
you're not gonna figure out just by
thinking about it you're gonna figure it
out by going out and doing and saying
yes and say yes and say yes and say yes
I say yes until you find something not
that you just absolutely fall in love
with or that you want to come back and
do again so as an example in my life at
one point I picked up salsa dancing I
picked up snowboarding I picked up rock
climbing I hated the rock climbing I'm
afraid of heights but I didn't say no to
it I'm willing to try it once just to
see I didn't like how the harness was
bothering me and that was a one-time
thing and I didn't go back I picked up
snowboarding and I really liked it and I
went back and I did it again and again
and again and the next winter I went
every single day almost snowboarding I'm
answering emails on the ski lift going
up and I spent an hour to two hours
every morning practicing my snowboarding
skills but then I stopped I lost
interest in it and I haven't gone at all
this winter yet I picked up salsa
dancing and on paper
I shouldn't be into salsa dancing I'm
really tall I don't speak Spanish I take
huge stabs I didn't grow up with the
music there's so many things that are
against me but when I went I just liked
it I just really enjoyed dancing and
just really enjoyed connecting with
people and so I thought I'm gonna go
back and do it again and that's the key
you explore and explore and explore and
say yes and say yes and say yes until
you find the thing that you want to do
again just like when you go on a date
it's not do I want to marry this person
it's do I want to go on a second date
that's what you need to do until you
find the thing that you want to go back
to again and again and again well number
three is understand where time flies for
you if you want to have massive success
you want to be an entrepreneur you want
to build your business you want a happy
life it's important to find the things
that time flies for with you it's the
thing that you wake up and you start
doing and then you look down and it's
already 6:00 at night where did the time
go
things where you forget to go to the
bathroom you forget to eat for me it's
helping entrepreneurs this has been an
insane busy day for me I've been filming
videos all day long this is one of my
last ones to record we've had a lot of
fans for the channel stop by and say hi
and shake hands and take selfies and
tweet out pictures it's been really
amazing and it fuels me you know when I
forget to eat
I haven't had my lunch you know I've
only had coffee in a bar so far you know
I forget to go to the bathroom and I'm
probably gonna go home and crash and go
crazy but the point is I love doing this
kind of work and so if you can
understand where you get lost in if you
understand where you can wake up and
start working on something and all of a
sudden hours have passed by and you
don't know where the time went
that's a good indication that you really
like this thing and maybe that's a way
to turn that into a bigger passion
purpose for you
[Music]
weena before find out what energizes you
going on a mission of finding a life's
purpose and vision is a powerful one but
it needs to come from a place of energy
and excitement so before you even worry
about finding your life's purpose and
vision make a list of things that
excites you and energizes you and don't
judge at all you know it could be
something I was like I love listening to
children's laughter to going on a long
walk on a beach - fighting social
injustice
whatever it is make a list of that and
the second thing you want to do is
engage in it so for me I wasn't born
knowing what my life's purpose and
vision is it took a lot of me trying
things that energized me to get there
two things that brings me a lot of
excitement and energy is one being a
dance teacher when I used to teach dance
classes I would get lost in that world
and seeing my students laugh seeing them
connect with each other seeing them go
from a bigger nerd dancer to an advanced
dancer and seeing that transformation
just amazed me and on the other side I
loved having one-on-one conversations
with people I get completely lost in
their world look them straight in the
eyes and just really connect with them
and be present for them and both those
things I would walk away feeling so
energized and excited and no matter how
long I did those two things I never felt
tired but I still didn't really realize
what it is that my life purpose was at
that moment it wasn't until I kept on
engaging in those two things I started
finding clarity and the clarity was this
I loved seeing people transform in front
of my eyes
I love seeing people when they embrace
where they are and they go after the
things that they really want and me
being part of that journey is so
exhilarating for me and eventually I
turn my life's purpose into a business
today I'm a life coach that's what I get
to do every single day try to figure out
ways to help people get what they want
and that's a thing for you
instead of thinking about this big
massive thing about your life purpose
really just make a list of things that
energize you engage in it over and over
and over again and really see what the
connective tissue is and that will lead
to clarity and finding out what your
life purpose is we number five is find
out what you hate so just like way
number three looking at where you can
get lost in with your time when number
five is what do you hate doing what
feels like time stretches out forever
like doing this is just insanity and you
hate it and you never want to do it
again and you can't believe you're being
forced to do it and it just drives you
nuts you know we all have those things
in our life and so making a list of all
of those things that you hate doing then
think about it
what's the opposite what is the opposite
of that because if you hate doing these
things and you love doing these things
potentially and that can help you build
a list of new activities and things to
try out that might allow you to discover
your purpose way number six is asked a
million dollar question ask yourself if
you had a million dollars if you just
won the lottery
what would you do with your life what's
the first thing that comes to mind and
often the first thing is gonna be travel
vacation pay off my loans pay off some
debt buy my mom a house whatever that
stuff is great
okay assume you have enough money to
then pay for all of that - now what do
you do
you've traveled all you wanna you've
seen the entire world you've met all the
people you want to meet you've tried all
these great foods now what is it that
you want to do most people can't look
past the immediate gratification that
instant hit that they would get if they
got some money because they hate their
life so much they just want to escape
but after you've escaped you're still
looking for purpose after you've escaped
your copy life and you're you're
temporarily solving it you still want
some purpose if you've been deprived of
sugar then all you want to do is eat
sugar but you're not going to be
fulfilled and happy just
sugar all day long you're gonna want to
have some real food what's the real food
for you their vacations that travel all
that kind of stuff for most people is
just sugar it's just something you're
craving because you don't have any of it
in your diet right now right you have
such a crappy life for a lot of people
that you just want to go off and do
these things as an escape great that's
all now what do you do and so if you ask
yourself that question now start writing
down the things that come to mind that's
a great indication of where you should
be going anyway number seven is ask
yourself to seven days left to live
question so this is a great question
that I saw on one of Tony Robbins events
where if you had a week left to live
what would you do with it how would you
spend your time it's a question that we
ask here at Turner den salsa
sometimes to the students at the front
of the class if you only had seven days
left to live how would you spend that
time what would you do who would you see
what activities would you engage in
because when that fear of death is
actually coming you can shake off the
fears that other people will put on you
the judgments the expectations and
actually do the thing that you really
really really really really really want
to do and so I'd encourage you spend
some time take out a piece of paper
write at the top
if I only had seven days left to live I
would do and then try to come up with a
list of ten different things that you
would do for yourself and then look at
hmm how can I get started on this stop
waiting for that to be next year and
next year and next year and that never
actually happens and find a way to
within the next seven days actually
check some of those things off your list
thank you guys so much for watching I
would love to know which of the seven
ways resonated the most of you which
exercise you're gonna try immediately
leave it down the comments below
is there an eight nine ten that I missed
that you want to share I would love to
hear from you thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you that sums you up all that would
be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details